Norma bienvenida a Franz 24 cuéntenos
Cómo se o cómo se ha hecho la
programación de este festival Qué tipo
de películas han buscado presentar
Bueno muchísimas gracias Andrés por la
invitación este año tenemos 17 películas
entre animación documental ficción que
habla diferentes temáticas ambientales
incluido cambios climáticos cacería
ilegal especies como el jaguar que son
endémicas de Colombia y de latinoamérica
tenemos una programación con más de 70
proyecciones como usted bien lo decía de
las principales ciudades de Bogotá Pues
de Colombia en Bogotá y Medellín tenemos
más de 9 espacios entre salas de cine y
bibliotecas públicas de la red pública
de Bogotá bibliored Así que Esperamos
que las personas se hayan disfrutado
pues ya estamos cerrando el festival
mañana terminamos pero llevamos más de
10 días presentando problemáticas
ambientales alrededor con temáticas que
son globales y que nos competen a
nosotros en Colombia También usted lo
decía mañana termina ya este festival
que nos puede decir de la acogida del
público frente a la selección de este
año
Bueno pues tenemos una felicidad enorme
porque la gente ha respondido hemos
tenido salas llenas en las temática de
Bogotá donde nos encontramos en este
momento la gente ha respondido muy bien
porque tenemos contenido para niños
desde los tres cuatro años hasta adultos
Así que hemos visto que las personas
tanto en Bogotá como Medellín han
respondido positivamente a estas
temáticas porque creemos que cada vez
más la audiencia está buscando
respuestas y la cultura es sin duda ese
punto de conexión entre esas temáticas
ambientales que resultan a veces
difíciles de entender y el cine logra
Conectar a las personas con esas
problemáticas y hacer unos espacios de
reflexión para que cada uno de nosotros
pueda tomar decisiones y actuar
responsablemente para mitigar las
acciones temas ambientales el tema de
medio ambiente Norma está cada vez más
presente en los medios de comunicación
Usted cree que es un tema que inspira
también mucho a los directores
sí sin lugar a dudas desde 2013 que
empezábamos hasta hoy el número de
proyección de producciones
cinematográficas alrededor del mundo ha
crecido tenemos cada vez más películas
en diferentes géneros y pues eso es una
gran noticia porque quiere decir que
primero hay más productores interesados
en el contar este tipo de temáticas y
hay más audiencia y hay más salas de
cine abiertas a exponer este tipo de
contenidos no solo comerciales sino que
llevan un mensaje y tienen un sentido
muy importante en medio de la crisis
climática que estamos viviendo en todo
el mundo